وقد رحبت الاليه الثلاثيه المكونه من
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي وهيئه
الايجاد بتوقيع الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريعه على اعلان جده ورات
التوقيعه على اعلان جده خطوه مهمه لحمايه
المدنيين وحفظ كرامتهم كما رحبت قوى
الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي بالاعلاني
الانساني الموقع بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بجده من جهته قال المتحدثه باسم العمريه
السياسيه في السودان خالد عمر يوسف ان
توقيع الاتفاق يشكل خطوه اولى في الاتجاه
الصحيحه تحتاج ان تتحول لوقف للقتال
باليات واضحه للتنفيذ والمراقبه وذلك
لتسهيل ما وصفه بالخروج من كارثه الحرب
ودعا يوسف قاده القوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع الى التحلي بالاراده اللازمه
لمواصله هذا المسار ووقف القتال في اسرع
ما يمكن الجبهه الثوريه بقياده الهادي
ادريس رحبت بدورها بتوقيع الاتفاق وقالت
انه